[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen tralee will ja
heute gibt keine bio
ich habe nämlich am wochenende die eine
million abonnenten erreicht unglaublich
oder
als hier wirklich die letzten tage und
wochen auch schon fährt darauf
hingefiebert und wir waren alle wirklich
immer gespannt am handy und am laptop
und haben schon die minuten und stunden
gezählt wird es endlich soweit ist und
jetzt am wochenende es war das von tag
mittag um etwa vielleicht gar nicht wie
viel uhr sieglos zwei jahre ungefähr 14
uhr habe ich die eine million erreicht
vermitteln traurig denn der murat war
leider nicht dabei es gab noch ein
chicago auf der hausmesse und deswegen
weiter auf der messe zum glück war
freunde von mir da auch meinem team auch
verdiene und farben die die meinen shop
betreut und danach standen wir draußen
und haben einfach für penn die
reingeguckt und darauf gewartet ob sie
weiß wie eine million pro person können
wir natürlich nicht herausfinden aber
war einfach unglaublich also wirklich
eine million personen
ich habe euch damals angesagt ich wohne
in einem ort in watenbüttel mit 22.000
einwohnern und als ich damals die 20.000
22.000 erreicht habe ich kraft dann
wackelte guckst du so viele menschen
findet und wenn ich mal zum globus
einkaufen geht dann ist es immer so war
auch in ihr viele menschen von hier
elementen und jetzt muss eine million
unfassbar
ich habe mich einfach ernst
rückenausschnitt auf dem facebook video
ich habe hier eine million abonnenten
erreicht
gruppe 4 millionen abonnenten auf aber
ich keine kommentare
irgendwie eine million abonnenten ihr
seid doch warm sind die eine million und
die fläche jetzt gerade abonniert hat
ist für eine million abonnenten hammer
eine million zurück vor allem weil ich
seit zwei jahren etwa im august war habe
ich die 100000 erreicht und das war
schon eine mega zahl also bei den
sechsstelligen bereich zu gehen war für
mich war und dabei im urlaub das weiß
ich noch und jetzt gerade mal zwei jahre
oder eineinhalb jahre später habe ich
eine million erreicht und habe mir
gedacht ich mach balten rückblick video
und war wie sally welt angefangen hat
und wie wo ich jetzt stehe und wie wir
filmen zum beispiel weil ich nicht alles
aber das machen wir im fünfjahres
breschel
denn meine dort also meine fans nicht
mit völlig selbst gibt es schon seit
fünf jahren im april
und dafür gibt es unseren kleinen
rückblick video und ich glaube es wird
euch bestimmt ganz gut gefallen heute
ich mir gedacht feuerwehr eine million
möchte ich ein kleines rätsel machen und
zwar gibt's jetzt elf tage lang 1
prozent in meinem online shop da könnt
ihr gerne mal reinschauen und das möchte
einfach meinen dank den ich euch
zurückgeben kann natürlich würde ich am
liebsten mit euch allen und kaffee
trinken gehen so mein wunsch aber fehlt
leider nicht ihr könnt mich mal auf
messen zum beispiel besuchen oder bei
einer autogrammstunde oder einfach bei
einem anderen event die bekommt ihr
immer über meine homepage mit aber eure
kämpfer nachrichten und botschaften e
mail haben wir alle zeigen wer die
ganzen kommentare macht aber kam es
damit ganz gerührt hat dass du ein video
von meinen zuschauern die sich
zusammengeschlossen haben um die eine
million abonnenten mit mir feiern und
ich zeige euch einfach mal das video
zumindest nun auch der davon ausgeht
zehn minuten lang und ich muss dazu
sagen es hat mein make-up zerstört ich
musste an zu finden
[Musik]
bei einer beerdigung argumenten haben
ein lied um gedichte schlimmer unfall
möglich gemacht
[Musik]
im
du hast das du deinem da gibt's dann
dürfte der erfolg nicht mitradeln und
kuchen
[Musik]
weitermachen
alle kannst du tun mit der wechsel für
uns alle
das ist einfach toll
[Musik]
dieses video ja der murat wird dies auch
anfangen sobald er wieder da ist und wir
habe kann ich sagen ich kann mich ganz
herzlich bei allen bedanken
vor allem bei denjenigen die nicht von
anfang an begleiten seit fünf jahren
etwa aber auch bei allen die neu zu
erfinden vielen dank es kommentieren zu
bewerten um das teilen meiner video
es gibt natürlich weiterhin immer ganz
viele videos von mir dreimal die woche
kochen backen videos dann gibt's noch
zusätzliche videos und es macht mir
wirklich weiterhin unglaublich viel spaß
und ich muss auch sagen es macht von tag
zu tag mehr spaß weil man einfach immer
hand neue herausforderungen habt und das
thema wächst und von ihrer macht super
gerne mit murat macht ganz toll mit und
es hat wirklich wunderschön dass ich an
meine welt gefällt vielen dank an euch
alle und bevor ich jetzt noch
emotionaler werden
vom westen aus
[Musik]
[Applaus]
eine million mal
[Gelächter]
[Musik]